whatsapp ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovissimo video e io sono un po dj oggi
o un'ospite d'eccezione che con una
multa dietro è inutile che ti metti che
provoca diverso fra l'altro tanto ti
devo presentare un mio amico che adesso
ti faccio io ho molta prossima di
seguire posso dire ti preoccupare io ho
fatto le cose giuste riguardato anche la
cia le barche è comunque la cosa
importante è che ti devo far vedere oggi
è semplicemente la casa che mi sono
fatto in mezz'oretta nello scorso aprile
una casa va bene vai
no no ma guarda che sostengono me sono
stato bravi è forse la miglior partenza
di minecraft a quando giocava era debole
la detta esplode anche ricercando dentro
casa è sicuramente ma ti faccio
soprattutto conoscere un mio no ma che
hai fatto mai quella romanissimo vera
essenza impazzito perché cosentino e
giganti di 30 minuti e ho spaccato 26
mila alberi tratto mio amico che quello
là sopra lo vedi è lui proprio lui sia
fernando e lei mi ha seguito tutto il
tempo prima mentre spaccavo quegli
alberi li vedi ed è rimasto lì non si è
mosso quindi appena riammessi possono
prendere i cavalli romanini certo deve
solo trovare la persona che era una
rarissima e liquidare il nome è certo
così da una sella ti prego team e nei
dungeon il solito in casinò ce l'hai già
fatto la casa non ci sono non fate che
ti segue
allora senti ti presto casa mia adesso
che poi sul letto per te ce lo teniamo
la e così almeno le cose che facciamo le
possiamo fare bene perché poi quando tu
ti farai casa ti danno una mano
chiedevano cominci la feria fare casa
dove c'è il bambù
non so se è visto che c'è la zona con
bambù the nation arden minecraft ok
allora amico mio credo che sia l'orario
giusto per uscire è un pochino ma è
cruda se vuoi andare a casa di trevi
scotte e vai dove vuoi
coordina
allora pensavo che scendiamo andiamo a
fare le cose fatte bene facciamo che
scendiamo ma scusami ma a lanciarsi
sull'acqua da qua
peccato non si può fare ma bello poi
ischia celli cosa dell'acqua battuta mi
aspetto posso provare ma c'è cioè cielo
per poi 12 e non ci arrivi fa secco e ci
prova sceneggiato rai mai prova ci vai
[Musica]
era abbastanza ovvio che non ci saresti
arrivato all'ora secondo me ci sono due
obiettivi
una cosa è prendere un voto di pietro e
fare una fornace perché la carne cruda
non credo che la fornace cielo allora
perché non l'avevi fatta in casa perché
quanto d'altura l'episodio e io vorrei
in realtà volevo trovare la sella per
fermare no ma se matteo senti alle due
non è possibile accedere una palude mi
sa si sa che voglio voglio interrompersi
un attimo perché vedo una cosa che non
mi piace sta andando a fuoco col cosa
andiamo a spegnere un attimo perché vedi
perché da quando esistono i partner non
ci sono
voglio un panda fernando è che la juve
lo è trovare il panda raffreddati lei
fortuna ne troverai uno a chi sta con
disco di italo disco nel 2020 non è così
bello anche il 2020 poco il meme del
panda che saluti al bambino io non so di
che giornalmente è ma dovrebbe essere
una zona fatta apposta per andare
nell'header più easy però qui per te che
mi ruba tutto
cos'è che c'era convinti che nulla va
dai vago vendola gesta
non ho capito fallita negli addobbi
dissocio alcuni come un attimo diritto
ma scusa e voi ma si tratta da sola che
prima andava a fuoco da solo ha preso
fuoco dalla lava e questa zona penso che
ci sia di base che si auto forma perché
negli stalli reagire alle altre parti a
ripetere cose che c'erano tanto qua c'è
una c'è una sono presenti ei presunti
pieni i temi tieni a ok
oddio lavoratore ok ok da un pezzo ma
perché dai tutto scherzavo io ma anche
sei trovato incredibile però dei
problemi nome nomi di soldi se mi tengo
solo la spada d'oro incantata perché
incredibile ok allora perfetto se ci
pensi che veramente piano sto mondo
pieno di rober cioè è bello si studia
per ci potrebbe veramente studiare
insomma scoraggiano studieranno perché
incredibile dei verdi sicuro si siano
veramente ma io credo che posso dirti la
mia sui videogiochi parentesi culturale
vai dai videogiochi un giorno saranno
come adesso noi vediamo magari i libri
incredibili tipo il signore degli anelli
per dire no per ora non minecraft esatto
per lui è arrivata e la stoffa quindi
vede vediamo c'è un lama è meglio io
immagino che gli sputi in faccia per
l'audience mi fa anche male estivi
leggermente anche qua è un quanti gli
amici sono isto mondo spiega mi ma che
ne so se autogenera il mondo è credibile
vabbè pazzesco comunque poi detto gli
addetti ricorderei come tornare a casa
no però effettivamente c'è la casa su
una specie di altura quindi si dovrebbe
vedere che cosa che stavamo cercando
non mi ricordo più ma non vuoi provare a
vedere se c'è qualcosa nel dungeon tu
qua sotto e non la vedo un buco nella
montagna e andare andiamoci dai a questa
parte no mentre qui igiene dove c'è
un'apertura questo va bene così corri
oddio solo di sotto di noi e nino cori
aiuto bene c'è un creeper da mina mai
sei tu che c'è la spada dorata
incredibile
allora io 38 che seif non so dove sei
arrivo ovunque tu stia facendo poi
zombie crea delle torce non vedo nulla
mano come faccio io ho detto che non ci
ha già aspettava nella turistica non li
ho presi con gli presi e lasciati a
terra
nei 100 misti che aspettano altri però
anche certo che bene sia la tua spada ma
che dice come fai impossibile è anche i
pantaloni sono incentrati al momento e
ho capito però meglio la spada dei
pantaloni è infatti teresa grazie non
c'è niente però anche i quali non ho mai
capito se tu alimenti a scavare a quel
punto erano mico a random
però se noi continuiamo a scendere
quanto dico addio c'è un ragno mi sono
pagato che possono ma pedro che arrivò
però e le caverne si trovano più in zona
band rock dove siamo adesso va già bene
ma no potremmo già trovarla stiamo
avendo sfiga
allora facciamo così facciamo così
facciamo così e questo lo prendo per un
ferro vabbè 10 di ferro grazie a madonna
10 da solo una zona mandiamo a casa già
in metallo per niente tipo ho notato il
bedrock la peggio che andare a torno
ok una casa normale effettivamente
tu la file di norma in legno pressi
quindi il rischio fiamme ce l'hanno
tutti alla fine si vabbè ma il fuoco
soprattutto to sotto gli alberi non so
come dovrebbe accadere però giura a meno
che non sbaglia invece non è vero
ok il più probabile puramente sbaglio a
cucinare vuole ovvio quelle probabili ho
rischiato sta roba in casa mia vero non
ci sei tu mi hai tratto si è trovato the
paura perché è posto anche postaccio
siamo senti ho dato resto attenzione a
bresson sicuramente c'è qualcosa adesso
ma poi si chiama ne sono più piccoli di
metallo veramente è però così è
teoricamente nella regola base che siamo
vicini a della lava esatto me lo ricordo
ma io essenzialmente manco la sento
quindi vorrei capire dov'è non mi
ricordavo se sì che si sentisse la lava
e quanto prevede restano no che nei
dungeon è cambiato qualcosa nel tempo ma
forse ignora quando giochi tu mi sa di
no però sempre uguali per avare giovani
ok allora mi interessa tanto quale ok
caverna decente è un postaccio animato
di diamante o tratto diamanti a caso io
te lo giuro si tiri ancora e di alloggio
e adesso aspetta che arrivò 84 di diaman
genio vabbè un fenomeno ciao a tutti mi
dissocio guai un piccone mt alfano che
limita spada esatto il pugnale fa 26
essere utili per un posto strano
allenati aspetto intanto solo qualche
faccio e non posso fare niente analisti
però comunque il carbone dura un sacco è
porchi per fortuna si cerca magari di ri
picconare tutto che così poi mi
raggiunge che stagione interessante
avete avuto una fortuna incredibile se
l'altezza giusta credi avanti però
trovarlo lì a caso è sempre bella cosa
veramente si incredibile bene sento la
va da 100 a 300 per cento quindi occhio
allora perché nel casinò nella lava
il fatto è che il vicino ci sono sempre
materiali abbastanza utile tipo il ferro
arrivo ha detto che lei ha opposto così
così per terra hai una cosa che ho visto
vieni da miramare ragazzi di persone
silverfish l'ho fatto ho fatto fuori fa
lessi silvano stt pensa cosa mai uniti a
lavori un arrivo perché non c'è una lava
di mezzo e fiona nomadi da pil da divo
cioè chiamate o da trial al quartiere va
beh uno stack incredibile allora è
incredibile e ho paura che tu muoia
quindi sto cercando di trovare a 10 o 10
diamanti aspetta che controllo anche
nella roccia di campo che gli amanti
pazzesco anche dal vivo fare la stessa
cosa di fuori che ho trovato un posto
fisso un po pericoloso fratello
va bene che mangia la carne cruda ho
capito sto morendo
guarda che posto incredibile se questa
roba addio mio man canyon canyon e
sotterrato un bravo visto pochi ma io
non mi vedo in lei la spada di tv e ddr3
che fa più danno la traccia purtroppo ma
cos è possibile allora l'insegnamento io
avrei questo smeraldo senti ma gli
smeraldi puoi scambiare per delle selle
per fernando
forse sì non lo sai può essere seconda
seguirebbero uno ti danno la pagnotta e
ti mandare a casa una bella smeraldo è
così e così veramente rare una sella e
vi ricordate la gravi come niente no non
si può trattare quello il problema
semmai non è ma non abbiamo mai stata
contattata sono io che mi ricordo
malissimo decisione le custom ap le
mettono facilmente trovabili nelle ceste
come prima
è emerso in vanilla normale un attimo
più complicato comunque affermando che
prima o poi la rai mi vuoi che sto
facendo mi sto complicando la vita e tu
sei arrivato limitate a strati facendo
dei casini che la grande per un
bellissimo vicolo cieco
perfetto per quali voi le notizie guarda
io sono già contento potremo tornare a
casa tranquillamente che cerchiamo era
un dungeon un po strano ma è proprio un
po di materiali ancora i nomi di quello
sì sì sì sì quello senza ombra di dubbio
però siamo messi da parte
gaga in mano vediamo va bene anche
perché c'è del vero è veramente o torce
ma manco io l'avessi skafar meno non
riesco a farne torce un attimo ma la
resta un tu dici che serve wireless se
ti posso ne prendi una star
se a posto per dieci anni perché ti ci
fai la bussola e poco più
allora sola serve così tanto è perché ti
riporta a casa tua tipo in questo caso
farebbe comodo ma sono capitato niente
fosse ok ci credi che c'è un altro
vicolo cieco non creda che la parte ci
sta è un canyon alla fine sotterraneo 5
starà a me interessava e sai come si
chiami spoon e dove la gente cerca forse
non lo sai chi l'acqua loro se chi
l'acqua tirati libero vieni qua quale
l'acqua c'è l'acqua infatti si dico sì
per quanto tre cuori mamma mia
ho avuto paura rispondere litro vini
dungeon è però sono rarissimi immagino
abbastanza secondo me se dobbiamo dare
non c'è nulla di utile alla fine come
tornano sul grande è vedere sopra però
mi sa che ci viene spammare strong alla
vecchia maniera i presenti si riesca a
farci sopra l'unico problema sai quale
come torniamo a casa
quello è un problema che dovrebbe
pensarci effettivamente adesso ci
troviamo una pozza di lava in faccia
subito per un attimo pensavo di essere
morto e tutto che mi facesse un sì
perché diceva molto paura o ragione ho
ragione ma scusami se c'è e che provate
un attimo buccino cd oggi avviene avere
gente non è vero quanto la vela d'oro
[Musica]
scoraggiata lanciato lanciato lasciato
maggiori ma perché sono un problema
cillis non spaccare blocchi
[Musica]